Hello and welcome to this episode,
where we are going to talk about
the European Union’s proposal for
an Artificial Intelligence act.
It was proposed by the European Commission
on the 21st of April 2021 and very recently
on the 14th of June this year, the European
parliament has voted on it. The whole AI act
is a document of almost 90 pages. It also comes
with a 10 pages summary, see the links in the
description below. In this video, we summarize
and break down the most important points for
you and tell you why this is important
for you even if you’re not an EU citizen.
But not before we thank Assembly AI, the sponsor
of today’s video! AssemblyAI offers superhuman
AI models for speech recognition, automatic
transcription, speech summarization, and more
through a secure and scalable API. As an applied
AI company, AssemblyAI’s mission is to empower app
builders to build 10 times faster, focus on their
specific use cases and user needs, and win market
share with a true technology partner. Last week,
AssemblyAI announced its new Conformer-2 model,
the company’s latest AI model for automatic speech
recognition that was trained on 1.1 million hours
of audio data. Now this week, AssemblyAI is
launching LeMUR, the easiest way to build LLM
apps on spoken data. Users can search, summarize,
ask questions, and generate new text, with
knowledge of all an application’s spoken data.
LeMUR performs intelligent retrieval to offer
high-quality LLM responses with a single API call.
You can play around with both Conformer-1 and
LeMUR in their free AI playground with the link
in the description below. Now, back to the video.
The EU has a draft on the AI act, so it is not
yet enforced, as it is still to be approved and
adopted by the member states. So, why did the EU
feel like there is need of an AI act? Because on
the one hand, AI can benefit society by
helping science, and improving health,
by finding new drugs for example, it can help us
with protecting the environment, it can help in
transport by optimizing bus routes and estimated
time of arrivals, it can help feed the population
by optimizing agriculture. And the list of the
benefits can go on and on. But on the other hand,
AI can also have some questionable uses. For
example, it can help social media companies
make more money because AI algorithms help them
make you stay engaged on their platforms. And
even worse, AI is a double-edged sword that can be
used in even more concerning applications such as
face recognition at scale, social scoring and many
other applications that empower discrimination,
cut on the freedom of expression, and
can harm data protection and privacy.
So, the aim of the EU AI act is to regulate AI
to protect its citizens from harm enabled by AI,
while still fostering AI innovation for good
applications. It is important to understand here,
that this AI Act is by design a product safety
regulation, think CE label on electronics, safety
standards for personal protection equipment and
so on. It is not intended to slow technological
advancements, but rather to make sure that AI
products on the market don’t harm anyone. The EU
wants to step in on AI matters especially since so
far, authorities cannot step when it comes to uses
AI. An EU-wide regulation would avoid fragmented,
country-wide measures that would make using an AI
produced and regulated in an EU country difficult
in another one. A clear stance of governments on
AI would also make the current situation better in
which the legal uncertainty discourages businesses
to use and rely on AI systems. And I think it’s
understandable that I am a bit dissuaded to use
AI generated pictures in my videos because
who knows if following a new law, I might be
banned in the future from showing my videos with
such content in the US or another country. The
world so far has been quite slow in making laws
about AI. Much slower than the technological
progress. For example, the United States were
very hands-off in regulating AI so far. Who
knows whether this might change with the recent
senate hearings. This AI act draft makes the EU
the first to have a serious regulatory proposal
on AI. Then, let’s see what the AI act contains.
To whom does this regulation apply to? We
cite “The new rules would apply primarily to
providers of AI systems established within
the EU or in a third country placing AI
systems on the EU market or putting them into
service in the EU, as well as to users of AI
systems located in the EU.” Interestingly,
it does not apply for military purposes. Aha.
But what does even count as AI according to
the EU? We know that the definition of AI is
very debated, even by experts. In this draft, AI
is, we quote: “...software that is developed with
[specific] techniques and approaches [listed in
Annex 1] and can, for a given set of human-defined
objectives, generate outputs such as content,
predictions, recommendations, or decisions
influencing the environments they interact with.”
End quote. Hm, do you agree with this definition?
There are stakeholders who think this definition
is too broad. And they do have a point since this
definition even applies to a simple search through
the internet if powered by a neural network.
Should that be regulated too? Ms. Coffee bean’s
take here is the following: It does not matter how
AI is implemented, but its application. She does
not care what the technology or algorithm behind
a task is, but the task itself. Like, should
we care whether face recognition is implemented
by the latest in machine learning, such as deep
neural networks or if it is a very complicated and
lengthy if-else algorithm? It is the application
here that matters. The problem that advancements
in AI have brought is that before, we could not
do face recognition or deepfakes at scale and
now we can. If the definition of AI is narrow and
only includes deep neural networks, then one could
circumvent it. How? With an if-else program.
Ah, but there is no super complicated if-else
program that does face recognition, but what if I
take a neural network that does face recognition,
use another neural network to transcribe me the
patterns of the first network into a humanly
impossible lengthy to write if-else algorithm?
So, in my opinion, not the technology, but the
applications should be regulated. And we’ll see,
this is the way which the EU follows as well,
where not the technology, but the task it
solves is the one posed under scrutiny.
So, how does it to it, to regulate this software?
Well, by distinguishing between AI systems
posing (i) unacceptable risk, (ii) high risk,
(iii) limited risk, and (iv) low or minimal risk.
Unacceptable risk would be prohibited because it
is “considered to be a clear threat to people's
safety, livelihoods and rights.” Such unacceptable
Risk AI would use manipulative ‘subliminal
techniques’ (curious what that means) or would
be exploiting vulnerable groups (with physical
or mental disability). Social scoring is also
unacceptable or biometric identification such
as face recognition in public spaces. But there
are exceptions: In cases like serious crime,
if an EU arrest warrant has been issued, remote
biometric identification systems may be used.
As for high risk systems, they create adverse
impact, such as  Biometric identification
and categorisation of natural persons;
 Management and operation of critical
infrastructure;  Education and
vocational training;  Employment,
worker management and access to self-employment;
 Access to and enjoyment of essential private
services and public services and benefits;
 Law enforcement;  Migration, asylum and
border control management;  Administration
of justice and democratic processes. These
high-risk systems would be following new rules:
they will need to receive a CE registration,
just like all electronics, toys, personal safety
equipment and so on, that are sold on the European
market. For that they need to conform to
the safety legislation of their own field
(just like medical devices are) and to another
range of requirements such as risk management,
testing, technical robustness, data training and
data governance, transparency, human oversight,
and cybersecurity, all checked by a third party
before being placed on the market or put to use.
As for AI of “limited risk”, these are systems
that, we cite “interact with humans (i.e.,
chatbots), emotion recognition systems,
biometric categorisation systems,
and AI systems that generate or manipulate
image, audio, or video content (i.e.,
deepfakes) [They] would be subject to a
set of transparency obligations”. These
requirements include description of
data sources for training the model,
inclusion of standardised benchmark scores
and disclosure of machine generated content.
On a first glance these obligations maybe seem
reasonably easy to comply with, but none of the
current foundation models, from GPT-4, Stable
Diffusion to even Luminous, which was created
as a more “EU friendly” model, could comply
with these obligations if they were in place
today. This study from Stanford University’s
Center for Research on Foundation Models
https://crfm.stanford.edu/2023/06/15/eu-ai-act.html
shows that for example, almost all models except
for GPT-NeoX or BLOOM, use copyrighted data
for training or did not disclose that they
did not use copyrighted data. Very few models
disclose the compute and energy requirements,
their data sources or conduct
extensive evaluations or testing.
And lastly, for low or minimal risk
AI, the EU imposes no obligations.
There will be AI supervisory and surveillance
authorities at national level to supervise
the implementation of the regulation and
administer fines depending on the severity
of the infringement (up to €30 million or 6
% of the total worldwide annual turnover).
To foster developments and encourage startups,
the Commision proposes regulatory sandboxing,
which is, we cite “a controlled environment
that facilitates the development, testing
and validation of innovative AI systems (for a
limited period of time) before they are put on the
market […] . Sandboxing will enable participants
to use personal data to foster AI innovation,
without prejudice to the GDPR requirements.” End
quote. Since none of this is implemented yet,
it is easy to feel unsecure about how this
will develop, since we do not know yet if
every nation will be able to assemble
a worthy board of experts for this.
Will the AI act also apply to research? We
got to ask this question in our interview
with the EU parliament members in charge of
the AI act themselves, and the answer is no,
this act will not really affect researchers. As
long as AI is developed and released as research
and not as a product, it does not fall under
this regulation. So, a website with a model
demo from research or code to it should be fine.
But when a company is making money by making
it a product, it falls under the regulation.
If you’re using AI tools yourself, for example
to generate images or by getting help from ChatGPT
to write text, these regulations will likely not
affect you very much. As this regulation has
its basis in product safety regulation, the
major focus of it is to make sure companies don’t
put products on the market that impose a danger on
consumers. But as an individual, you are free to
use the products that are certified as you wish.
What you might see are watermarks to indicate
AI generated content as such, which come as
part of the transparency regulations for limited
risk AI systems. Of course, if you want to use an
AI system that the EU deemed unsafe to use, you
will not be able to get access to it in Europe.
I know, many of you are not from the EU, so you
might think that this does not really affect you.
But the past has shown that regulations
that apply to the European market often
affect the global market as well, since a lot of
producers sell to Europe and must conform to its
standards. This is known as the Brussels effect:
https://en.wikipedia.org/wiki/Brussels_effect
Just like with the California effect in the US,
companies that try to sell their products on the
global market will often try to comply with
the most stringent standard available. This
way they won’t have to design different
products for different markets and will
still be able to export to the whole world.
This was already the case for the production
of chemicals, airplane emissions and more recently
data protection, where now major US tech companies
implemented the European GDPR compliance for
all their customers, even outside of the EU.
And this was our summary about the AI act. What
are your thoughts on it? It is a good start,
but we will see how it develops. As stated by Mr.
Tudorache in our interview, it will take a while
until the law will come into effect, maybe
we will need to wait until 2026. But surely,
companies that want to become future proof
may want to already start complying with
these new rules. In fact, while preparing
this video, seven leading AI companies
in the US have signed an agreement to put
some safeguards on their products. For now,
this is just voluntary self-regulation, but it
is a first step. If you want to hear first-hand
from the regulators, check out our interview
on the channel of the European Parliament.
We hoped you liked this video and don’t forget
to subscribe to also see our next one. Okay, bye!